[Applaudissements]
comment pourrait-on faire progresser
l'enseignement dans toutes les classes
et faire progresser les apprentissages
pour tous les élèves
vous avez certainement une idée là
dessus parce que sur l'éducation
tout le monde a un avis nous avons tous
été élève
et donc nous avons tous un certain vécu
de skis a réussi pour nous et de ska
moins réussi beaucoup d'entre nous sont
aussi des parents d'élèves ce qui nous
offre une autre perspective sur le sujet
certains d'entre nous sont même des
enseignants et puis nous sommes tous
exposés aux discours des experts de
l'éducation voire même des gourous de
l'éducation chaque année il se publie
quelques dizaines de livres sur le sujet
qui nous disent tous que nous devons en
pensez et si on analyse le discours de
ces experts on constate vite qu'eux ils
disent à peu près tout et son contraire
bon mais alors est ce qu ils peuvent
tous avoir raison probablement pas mais
comment on va faire pour savoir qui a
raison et qui a tort et de manière plus
générale comment peut-on faire pour
savoir ce qui marche et ce qui marche
moins bien en éducation
la première idée de bon sens qui vient
c'est de se dire on va demander aux
enseignants
après tout les enseignants c'est eux qui
mettent en oeuvre des pratiques
pédagogiques et qui en observe les
effets sur les élèves
donc ils doivent bien savoir ce qui
marche on pourrait aussi se demander si
on devrait pas demander l'avis aux
élèves les élèves ce sont eux les sujets
d apprentissage et ils doivent bien
savoir dans quelles conditions ils
apprennent bien est temps quelles
conditions ils apprennent moins bien et
puis on pourrait aussi vouloir un point
de vue un petit peu plus distant et un
observateur indépendant
par exemple un inspecteur ou un
chercheur au fond de la classe qui
observent à la fois les pratiques des
enseignants et les apprentissages des
élèves et qui établit le lien entre les
deux ce sont toutes des bonnes idées
mais le problème avec ces bonnes idées
c'est que elles ne permettent pas
d'avoir une évaluation fiable de
l'efficacité des pratiques pédagogiques
pourquoi parce que
un professionnel qui observe les faits
de ses propres pratiques court un grand
risque de se leurrer on le sait
notamment grâce à l'histoire de la
médecine penser à ces médecins qui
pendant 2000 ans ont pratiqué la saignée
sur leurs patients vous savez la saignée
cette pratique qui consiste à ouvrir une
vaine et a laissé couler le sang du
patient dans l'espoir qu'il guérisse de
sa maladie vous vous savez que quand on
perd du sens et pas très bon pour la
santé mais les médecins à l'époque il ne
le savait pas il ne le savait pas mais
quand même ils ont pratiqué la saignée
chacun au cours de sa carrière sur des
centaines de patients
ils ont eu l'occasion d'observer l'effet
de la saignée sur l'état de santé de
leurs patients et envers et contre tous
que leur disaient les yeux ils sont
restés convaincu que la saignée
permettait au patient de guérir et ils
en sont restés tellement convaincus
qu'ils ont transmis cette croyance à la
génération suivante de médecins et ainsi
de suite pendant 2000 ans rendez compte
2000 ans comment c'est possible de se
leurrer sur des choses aussi basiques
pendant 2000 ans et bien c'est possible
parce que nous sommes des êtres humains
et nous sommes victimes de biais
cognitifs par exemple le biais de
confirmation
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit du fait que
nous avons tous des croyances des
croyances par exemple sur ce qui marche
et sur ce qui marche pas et lorsque nous
observons des résultats des données et
bien nos observations sont biaisés par
ses croyances
lorsque nous voyons des résultats qui
semblent conforter nos croyances alors
là nous leur accordons une grande
importance
mais lorsque des résultats semblent
contredire nos croyances nous les
ignorons nous les voyons même pas où
nous les oublions très vite et c'est
ainsi que nous nous renforcions
perpétuellement dans les mêmes croyances
ceci pour dire qu'un professionnel
qu'observent les faits de ses propres
pratiques et bien ils courent un grand
risque de se leurrer c'est vrai aussi
pour l'observateur plus indépendants qui
au fond de la classe qui lui aussi à des
croyances sur ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas et qui va aussi être biaisé
par ses croyances donc
il est clair qu'il nous faut d'autres
méthodes des méthodologies un petit peu
plus expérimental donc par exemple testé
un groupe d'enfants l'exposé à une
méthode pédagogique particulière pendant
une certaine durée d'intervention
et puis voir dans quelle mesure ils ont
appris après l'intervention mais
évidemment il faut comparer le niveau
qu'ils ont atteint dans l'incompétence
cible entre après et avant
l'intervention
en comparant les deux on peut en déduire
les progrès qu'ils ont fait grâce à la
méthode alors qu'ils ont progressé entre
les deux temps est ce qu'on peut dire
que ça prouve l'efficacité de la méthode
malheureusement non le problème c'est
que sur une durée donnée les enfants il
progresse toujours
parce que imaginer sur quelques mois ils
grandissent leur cerveau matures ils
font plein d'apprentissage à la fois
dans la classe en dehors de la classe et
donc sur n'importe quel test ils vont
toujours s'améliorer sur quelques mois
donc le seul fait de les voir progresser
ne prouve pas l'efficacité de la méthode
la bonne question à se poser c'est
est-ce qu'ils ont progressé plus du fait
de la méthode 1 que si ils avaient été
exposés à une autre méthode à une autre
pratique d'enseignement ce qui nous
conduit à faire des expériences avec un
groupe contrôle ou un autre groupe qui
fait l'objet d'une méthode b et aussi
d'en mesurer le niveau au début et après
l'expérimentation est donc ainsi en
ayant un groupe contrôle ou au moins
plusieurs groupes qui sont comparés on
peut à la fin comparez statistiquement
les progrès des élèves entre ceux qui
étaient dans le groupe à et dans le
groupe b et si leurs progrès diffèrent
eh bien on pourra dire avec un certain
niveau de confiance que c'est dû à la
différence d'efficacité entre les
méthodes voilà une méthodologie qui
permet mieux que le ressenti des
professionnels d'évaluer et de comparer
l'efficacité de différentes méthodes
pédagogiques
alors vous me direz c'est une méthode
bien compliqué bien assez lourd c'est
complexe ça coûte cher et au respect
peut pas demander à des enseignants de
faire ça pour évaluer leurs pratiques
et oui je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
lourd c'est complexe et coûteux et non
les enseignants peuvent pas faire ça
tout seul mais quand même c'est possible
ça se fait pas beaucoup en france mais
ça se pratique beaucoup dans d'autres
pays en 2008 le chercheur néo zélandais
jonah ati a fait une synthèse de tous
ses travaux de recherche expérimentaux
sur l'éducation il a trouvé plus de
50000 étude qui portait sur plus de 100
millions d'élèves dans plusieurs
dizaines de pays et depuis 2008 il s'est
écoulé 10 ans et le volume de résultats
qui a été publiée à peu près doublé dont
vous rendez compte on est à cent mille
études
c'est pas comme si on savait rien dans
l'éducation on s'est énormément de
choses on est assis sur une mine d'or de
résultats sur l'efficacité relative de
différentes pratiques pédagogiques il
tient qu'à nous d'aller puiser dans
cette connaissance
c'est ce qu'on appelle la proche de
l'éducation fondées sur des preuves qui
dit simplement que plutôt que ceux de
fonder sur des croyances ou des
idéologies et bien on a intérêt à se
fonder sur des données factuelles issues
d'études expérimentales pour guider la
politique éducative
je vais maintenant vous illustrer cette
approche par quelques résultats
marquants une première question qui se
pose à tous les enseignants c'est savoir
comment gérer l'hétérogénéité dans leur
classe c'est un véritable casse tête
entre le niveau du meilleur et le niveau
du plus faible
on a des différences qui sont parfois
extrême comme en est ce qu un enseignant
peut enseigner d'une manière qui est
adapté à la fois aux meilleurs et aux
plus faibles
ça paraît un casse tête insoluble alors
une manière de réagir qui semble de bon
sens c'est de se dire ah oui mais en
fait on fait plus redoublée les élèves
maintenant ils passent toujours dans la
classe supérieure
et du coup c'est ça qui crée de
l'hétérogénéité donc si on voulait
rendre les classes plus homogène
il faudrait réinstaurer plus de
redoublement de manière à ce que les
élèves qui n'ont pas les acquis
poursuivre dans la classe supérieure
eh bien ils les confortent dans la même
classe alors ça paraît une idée de tout
à fait bon sens maintenant il est temps
de la confronter aux données des études
internationales sur le sujet on a plus
de 200 étude qui porte sur les faits du
redoublement qui ont été effectués sur
plus de 14 mille élèves et ses études
disent de manière assez clair que le
redoublement n'est pas une pratique
efficace en tout cas du point de vue de
l'élève qu'il redouble
dans son année de redoublements il va
progresser l'équivalent de quatre mois
de moins d'apprentissage sur une année
scolaire que le même élève de même
niveau s'il était passer dans la classe
supérieure
quatre mois sur une année scolaire c'est
énorme le problème vous voyez c'est que
quand on redouble
on repart à zéro on refait les mêmes
cours les mêmes programmes ces terrains
c'est très ennuyeux et on est découragés
démotivés évidemment quand le même élève
passe dans la classe supérieure c'est
difficile aussi pour lui il aura du mal
à rattraper ses lacunes mais il est tout
de même tiré vers le haut par les
nouveaux programmes les nouveaux
camarades les nouveaux profs donc le
redoublement n'est certainement pas une
méthode efficace pour gérer
l'hétérogénéité des classes alors une
autre idée de bon sens qui s'offre à
nous c'est celle de faire des classes de
niveau puisque si on met les élèves
forts dans des classes forte et les
élèves faibles dans les classes faible
par construction on aura produit des
classes plus homogène dans lesquelles
les enseignants vont pouvoir programmer
un enseignant plus cohérent plus adaptés
au niveau de chaque élève
regardons le ce que disent les études
expérimentales
il y en a aussi un grand nombre est ce
que montrent ces études c'est que pour
les élèves qui sont dans les classes
forte
les classes de niveaux permettent de
progresser un peu plus que s'ils sont
dans les classes hétérogènes
en revanche pour les élèves qu'on a mis
dans les classes faible eux ils vont
progresser beaucoup moins que s'ils
étaient dans les classes hétérogènes et
du coup si on compile les faits moyens à
travers tous les élèves
eh bien il progresse un petit peu moins
que dans des classes hétérogènes environ
un mois de moins par année scolaire
autrement dit c'est un cas type de
fausse bonne idée à la fois on réduit un
petit peu le niveau moyen des élèves et
en plus on augmente les inégalités ce
qui est certainement pas une bonne idée
dans un pays comme la france qui est
championne des inégalités alors comment
on peut faire pour gérer ce vrai
problème que l hétérogénéité dans les
classes et bien ce que suggèrent les
recherches c'est que on peut faire des
groupes de besoins similaires au sein de
la classe c'est-à-dire des groupes
d'élèves qui sont similaires d'un
certain point de vue à qui on va pouvoir
donner des activités pédagogiques
différencier la grosse différence avec
les classes de niveau
c'est que ces groupes ne sont pas rigide
une l'enfant qui ne reste pas dans un
groupe donné dans toutes les matières et
tout au long de l'année
les groupes sont constitués en fonction
des besoins des élèves dans chaque
matière et à chaque moment de l'année en
fonction de leur progression les
recherches montrent que sous ces
conditions les élèves peuvent
progressiez mieux que dans les classes
hétérogènes
bien entendu cela suppose une formation
spécifique des enseignants parce que ce
sont des pratiques auxquelles ils sont
souvent peu habitué une autre
problématique est celle de riz d'arriver
à enseigner à des enfants qui sont
intrinsèquement différents et qu'ils
apprennent de manière différente
en effet il est bien connu que certains
élèves apprennent en voyant les choses
de manière visuelle d'autres élèves
apprennent de manière auditive et encore
d'autres élèves apprennent en touchant
en manipulant par conséquent le bon sens
suger de d'enseigner à ses élèves dans
la modalité qu'il aurait préféré de
présenter les contenus pédagogiques aux
élèves sous la forme visuelle pour les
visuels sous la forme auditif pour les
auditifs et c'est là encore beaucoup de
recherches sur le sujet qu'ils disent de
manière assez clair que non d'abord il
n'y a pas de base scientifique à cette
idée de sous type d'apprentissage visuel
auditif ou tactiles et deuxièmement
quand on enseigne à un élève dans la
modalité présumé préférées eh bien il
n'apprend pas mieux que si on lui
enseigne dans une autre modalité donc là
encore fausse bonne idée
ce que montrent les recherches c'est que
nous apprenons tous mieux si on nous
fournit l'information sous de multiples
modalités à la fois visuelle auditive et
éventuellement plus autrement dit ce
qu'on peut vraiment recommandé aux
enseignants c'est lorsqu'il enseignes de
présenter leurs contenus pédagogiques à
la fois de manière auditive verbal de
manière visuelle à la fois à l'écrit et
avec des illustrations et lorsque c'est
possible avec des objets à manipuler ou
des actions à faire et au quelqu'un on
peut effectivement amélioré les
apprentissages
une dernière problématique qui concerne
tous les enseignants du monde c'est
celle de gérer les comportements
perturbateurs qui nous le savons tous
entrave les apprentissages de tous les
élèves dans la classe y compris des
élèves auteurs de ces comportements le
bon sens suggère que on ne doit pas
tolérer de tels comportements et que
probablement on est trop laxiste avec
eux et qu'il faudrait sans doute les
punir plus systématiquement de manière à
les faire disparaître et à mieux les
dissuader pourtant les punitions ont de
nombreux effets pervers
tout d'abord elle déclenche des émotions
négatives chez l'élève qui est puni vous
me direz c'est peut-être un petit peu
l'objectif mais en soi c'est quand même
pas vraiment souhaitable d'autant plus
que ces émotions négatives peuvent
déclencher des comportements
perturbateurs eux mêmes des
comportements violents ou des
comportements de retrait ou d'évitement
et puis en étant puni l'élève apprend
une association entre l'émotion négative
ressenti lors de la punition et
l'enseignant qu'il punit et plus
généralement la classe l'école le
contexte scolaire
autrement dit ils acquièrent une
aversion pour l'enseignant et pour
l'école ce qui est probablement
contre-productif enfin lorsqu'un élève
est puni de manière répétée il finit par
se désensibiliser des effets de la
punition
et du coup la punition n'a plus l'effet
dissuasif sur le comportement et les
comportements perturbateurs vont
continuer voire vont s'aggraver et les
punitions vont aussi devenir de plus en
plus sévères et on va aboutir à une
escalade de la gravité de la
perturbation et de la punition une
escalade dont on sait qu'elle n'a pas
d'issue positive généralement et qu elle
culmine dans l'exclusion de l'élève qui
n'est évidemment pas une solution ni
pour l'élève ni pour le système scolaire
alors que pourrait-on faire de mieux
de plus efficace que le système
répressif actuelle est bien de
nombreuses études suggèrent qu'on peut
mettre en oeuvre des méthodes
comportementales
c'est à dire des méthodes qui analyse
finement le comportement de l'élève
les facteurs qui déclenchent son
comportement et les facteurs qui
renforcent son comportement et le
maintienne et à partir de là utilisé de
manière prioritaire des récompenses
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut s'interdire
d'utiliser des punitions mais plutôt un
dernier recours et dans des conditions
très précises
l'idée clé de ces méthodes c'est la
suivante c'est que lorsque on punit un
comportement perturbateur cela
n'enseigne pas à l'élève les
comportements qui devrait le remplacer
et donc l'idée clé c'est à partir d'un
comportement perturbateur d'identifier
le comportement positif opposés et à
partir de là de renforcer ce
comportement positif opposé en le
récompensant et à force de récompenser
ce comportement positif opposé sa
fréquence va augmenter et il va
progressivement faire disparaître le
comportement perturbateur
là aussi ce sont des méthodes qui ont
prouvé leur efficacité mais qui
nécessite également une formation
spécifique car elles ne sont pas très
intuitive donc pour conclure ce que j'ai
essayé de vous montrer je vous ai
apporté quelques bonnes et quelques
mauvaises nouvelles
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que le bon
sens et l'intuition ne sont pas des bons
guides des bonne mesure de l'efficacité
des pratiques et nous devons nous en
méfier
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il existe
d'autres méthodes expérimentales
scientifiques qui nous permettent
d'évaluer de manière rigoureuse
l'efficacité des pratiques pédagogiques
la deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est que ces
méthodes ont déjà été utilisés dans des
dizaines de milliers d'études et donc il
ne tient qu'à nous de puiser dans cette
source de connaissances pour améliorer
les pratiques pédagogiques et puis bien
entendu cette masse de résultat n'a pas
réponse à tout il reste encore plein de
questions ouvertes dans l'éducation
nous savons que nous avons une méthode
et que nous pouvons appliquer cette
méthode pour expérimenter tester de
nouvelles pratiques pédagogiques
découvrir lesquels marche le mieux
et enfin améliorer la qualité de
l'enseignement et les apprentissages
pour tous les élèves
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yj